hi welcome I'm navneet sneha I lead
product management for App Engine and
compute engine and today we're here to
talk about how at Google were
reimagining the stack for computing in
the cloud we'll spend some time talking
about Google container engine the new
service we launched this morning that
lets you run continued eyes applications
effectively in the cloud we'll talk
about how App Engine our platform as a
service offering is evolving and then
we'll spend some time talking about what
you can expect from us in the days weeks
and months ahead so before I talk about
the next generation compute stack I'd
like to take a step back and talk about
the principles that informed our
thinking around what computing the cloud
should look like first we believe that
you shouldn't have to deal with
unnecessary stuff and by that I mean
that you should have the level of
control that makes sense for your
application but you shouldn't have to
deal with the things that don't add
value if you're spending your time on
operational tasks that aren't critical
to application you should be able to
delegate those tasks to the cloud
provider we also believe that cliffs are
for climbers and what I mean by that is
that if you're a climber you enjoy the
challenge of a new steep cliff right but
if you're a developer you don't want two
things to happen you don't want to have
discovered many weeks down or months
down the line when you build your
application that's something you wanted
to do doesn't quite work right ready to
throw it all out and start from scratch
or you don't want to find that when you
add the next feature in your application
everything's running well you suddenly
need to rethink how you build your
application and change a whole bunch of
stuff so we don't like those developer
experience cliffs we want to make sure
that the cloud doesn't exhibit those
properties and finally we believe that
one of the critical things that isn't
early isn't obvious early on is that
operation should be really easy
and so you should be able to design your
applications in a way that optimizes for
long term operability lower costs of
maintenance and faster iteration and so
to make that vision a reality we really
think about compute as not a set of
disconnected disjoint services that you
plumb together yourself but rather as a
continuum where you have access to
different levels of abstraction and can
pick the right abstraction that makes
sense for your application or even for a
component of that application and if you
decide to change your mind down the line
you should be able to do so without
riorca tech ting everything without
throwing out a bunch of code and
starting again and so concretely what
that means in the cloud platform at
Google is three things the lowest level
abstraction we have is the virtual
machine this is compute engine that's
you run pretty much anything gives you a
very high level of control you can run
any colonel any operating system you
want any file system you want you can
tweak Colonel parameters whatever you
need to do you can do it right there but
let's say you don't actually care about
all those physical parameters you're
running a pretty standard application
everything just works normally without
doing any crazy tweaks to the colonel
you should be able to stop thinking
about that physical layer and instead
focus on logical infrastructure at the
cluster level where really you tell us
in a declarative way what the state you
want the system to exhibit is and then
we turn around and make that state or
reality and best of all if you are able
to just focus on your application on the
code you want to write to add value for
your customers your developers your
users you should be able to bring code
to the cloud platform benefit from a
rich set of curated runtimes a set of
services that give you underlying
foundational capabilities that you can
use to build your application and let us
automatically manage everything that can
be automated and bring your own code and
run it on the platform so let's talk
about the vm abstraction compute engine
it was built to offer you cost-effective
access to on-demand computing in other
words you should be able to come and
spin up compute resources in the cloud
when you want it and pay for those
resources
only when you're actually using them we
wanted to make sure it was flexible
enough to let you run pretty much
anything and we wanted to make sure that
it was rock solid so that higher level
abstractions could be built above it
both the abstractions that we build at
Google but also the abstractions that
are emerging in the open source
community the abstractions that the
ecosystem that has strung up around
cloud builds so we wanted to make sure
that the foundational building block was
really solid and to do so we wanted to
do three things we wanted to make sure
you benefited from Google's quality the
quality of service we can provide we
wanted to make sure that regardless of
the size of your application you benefit
from Google scale and we wanted to do
all this at a great price let's take a
step deeper and talk about what that
means and some of the key highlights in
those three areas first we wanted to
make sure that the underlying building
block was both predictable in terms of
performance and reliable so you could
really focus on building your
application not trying to keep it keep
it up and running we also wanted to make
sure that storage was available to you
in a manner that was secure so it was
encrypted at rest all our storage
offerings are encrypted at rest and
similarly our networks are encapsulated
fully at the project level so that you
have access to a private network within
your project which is also global and
the benefit of that is that you can
actually turn around and build an
application that is global in nature
that has components that might live in
multiple locations around the world and
you can wire those components together
without having to do you know weird
network tricks to get them to talk to
each other in a manner that's secure we
wanted to make sure that the impact of
proactive maintenance that every
everybody has to do whether you're
building your own private data center or
whether you're using the cloud proactive
maintenance on the underlying hardware
the operating system is critical and we
wanted to make sure that we could do
that regularly to give you the best most
up-to-date infrastructure keep it as
reliable as possible but without
impacting of applications so we built
transparent maintenance in to compute
engine so that we can you know keep our
systems running as efficiently as
smoothly as possible without subjecting
you to downtime and then we wanted to
make sure that the compute and storage
offerings available to you was suitable
for a large variety of workloads whether
you're running a small application or a
big one we wanted to make sure that you
if it from Google's scale and so even
though we regularly spin up clusters
that are in excess of a thousand nodes
in minutes at Google and on compute
engine we also wanted to make sure that
even our smallest customers who run in
just one or two VMs get the benefits of
that scale by benefiting from the
extremely fast startup times we wanted
to make sure that the cross sectional
bandwidth the bandwidth between
different virtual machines in your
project is as high as possible as
consistent and performant as possible
because that turns out to be a key
bottleneck for scaling if it doesn't
work well and we wanted to make sure
that if you have an i/o sensitive
workload let's say database Cassandra or
any other kind of high io workload we
wanted to make sure the storage
offerings we gave you we're not just
convenient abstractions but also gave
you the high performance and the
predictable predictable speed that you
expect for those kinds of applications
and then finally we focused on making
sure that all this was available at a
great price and that's not just making
sure that we lead the prices that lead
lead the world in terms of how we price
our our raw building blocks but also in
terms of how you benefit from using
those resources when you need them so
for example if you're running a short
workload and you were in the keynote
this morning you saw how much you
benefit from just having to pay for the
minutes you use your VMs but if you
aren't running a sustained workload it
turns out that that actually is cheaper
to run anywhere on premise or in the
cloud because you don't have to buff
provision a bunch of buffer capacity to
handle spikes so you know if you're
running on premise your cost on
on-premise are lower for sustained work
shows and for the cloud provider it's
lower for serving a sustained workload
and we want you to make sure that you
benefit from the characteristics of your
workload without having to make a
long-term commitment without having to
choose a specific vm size or even commit
to us you note running your workload on
Google to get those benefits so we
introduced automatic discounts when you
run sustained workloads you just run
your VMs and look the longer they run
the lower the average price goes and
although we've launched many features
and bass six six months on in our VM
offering I'd like to focus on to new
things we're talking about today the
first is the availability of local
solid-state drives so in the past we've
had high performance and you know high
throughput options magnetic ends and
solid-state
options for our network attached
persistent disk which is a great
offering but sometimes you just really
need to take it up a notch you need to
turn to 11 and he wants to have access
to local flash for your application
especially if you're doing something
like a very high performance Cassandra
cluster for example and the way that
works of cloud platform is is somewhat
unique you can take anyone plus core vm
so any standard vm any high memory vm
any high cpu vm i can attach flash to
that and you can do that in blocks of
124 375 gigabyte chunks and in doing so
you can get up to six hundred eighty
thousand read I oh and this is 4k random
reads better yet as you might know flash
devices need proactive maintenance as
well especially because of the way those
devices are built and often when you
decide to use flash for your workload
you have to deal with thinking about how
do i maintain that device so it keeps
running effectively we built transparent
maintenance to take care of that problem
for you as well so we extended our
transparent maintenance technology that
works in the data center for your VMs
and said if your flash device needs to
be maintained we'll transparently
migrate not just to vm but also your
storage and your application will keep
running and we keep the infrastructure
working really well it's available at a
great price less than 22 cents per
gigabyte per month and like all other
storage offerings it's encrypted at rest
we're also talking about compute engine
autoscaler this morning this is built on
the same auto scaling technology that we
at Google use to scale our own
applications so it's been proven and it
has a very simple and powerful
abstraction all you have to do is choose
a metric that you want to scale your
fleet based on let's say that's the CPU
use of your fleet you tell us what
target you want to head for that let's
say that's eighty percent and then you
walk away and our systems will take care
of spinning up VMs when your CPU
utilization you know goes goes up or
we'll take care of spinning down a few
of your CP utilization drops so we keep
your CPU utilization within those bounds
we support a bunch of different metrics
you can also scale based on custom
metrics in in cloud monitoring on the
utilization of your HTTP load balancer
best of all
well you don't need to pre warm your
application to get the benefits of auto
scaling once you've set those targets
and told us what you want to do it just
works and now to demonstrate that
propping so I know everyone we see able
to use the autoscaler that need just
introduced on a real world application
the go plague on some of you may be
already familiar with it it's a very
straightforward application you under
some go code I can say it'll gcp live I
click run and my code gets compile and
execute it somewhere in Google
infrastructure so we see I were to take
this application and run it on Google
cloud platform using the autoscaler that
Navin Eve just introduced so for that I
will run the command ok Google create a
notice cadet group of compute engine vm
running the go plug on it's not
implemented yet but I'm sure someone is
working on it somewhere so let's see how
we can do that this is the same thing
today using g-cloud so the first thing I
need to do is to tell compute engine
what I want to scale so for that I will
create a new instance known place I will
give it a name i will point to an image
that is a container of vm optimized
image it's a vm image that we distribute
that is optimized for container workload
and the last thing i need to do is to
point to a manifest this manifests will
define the containers that i want to
start with the vm so i have to wait for
the template to be created here it is
and next I need a group of VMs that I
need to create a group for my vm to
scale so for that i will use an instant
group a common goal i will define the
zone into which I want to run my vm here
i want to run them in us on high 1f we
gather name to the group and i will
point to the template that i just
created effectively telling to compute
engine to always create vm based on
these templates and the last thing i
need to do is to define an inch the
initial size for my god here I want nvm
so here it's creating my book in the
background so now that I have my
instance group I could stop there and
computer in general Apple II like
manages since we'll go for me then like
make sure there is always the always
Stan running at
any point of time if one goes down it
will be stopped a new one according to
the templates and I could next thing I
want to define is I want to scale those
vm so I want to create an autoscaler
object and I wait to tell compute engine
oh I want to scale so Soto scanner with
leaving the same zone as my instance
group I will give it a name i will
target the same group that I've dug is
that I've created before I will give it
a maximum number of instance that I want
to create here I want to scale up to 200
vm and i will also define a minimum of
instance i want to keep here when
scaling down i always want nvm and the
last thing is i need to define the
policy that the autoscaler will use in
order to decide if he needs to spin down
you via to spin up new vm of spindle
some here i'm going to scale based on
cpu utilization meaning here I I said
target CPUs addition to dot 5 which
means that across my feet when I reach
more than 50 personalization my
autoscaler we use that as a signal to
create new vm and when my across my feet
when I which I when I'm below this
relation the autoscaler will use that as
a signal to scale down so let's see at
stumps demo gun again and like see for
instance are running yet yes that's good
and I check your application serving
it's ready so let's take a look at this
IP and here we see the go playground the
same application that i introduced
before that is running on one of these
auto scale it back p.m. when i click run
it will contact the backhand and compile
and run my god code so when Navin Yvonne
tough stage I actually set up a load
test it cause notice Keller using a
similar setup and we'll see I was a load
test went like in the 10 minutes that
can from Nam leave entering stage 2 what
we are now so here we can see that in 10
minutes we went from just a few thousand
GPS to a more than one dot five million
KPS and we went from a tiny group of ten
instance to more than 200 instance rang
so this is like to show how to use the
autoscaler in action and with that we'll
go back to navigate thank you papi so to
recap you told us what you want to scale
you told us how you want to maintain the
right utilization and then we went from
zero to 1.5 million QPS in 10 minutes
yeah that's pretty much it you forgot
about is a pathway of the demo doing
quite well well that's that's 22 yes we
also think like the one my steam to the
demo gods and then yeah so 1 million
keep us pretty much like here is
everything so thank you papi so enough
about the vm abstraction let's take a
level up and think about logical
clusters and for that I'd like to
introduce Eric Conn product manager for
Google container engine
Thank You Napanee hi I'm Eric and thank
you for joining us the start of a new
product line is an important moment and
we at Google think that clusters are
going to be an important way for how
users compute going forward clusters
represent a fundamentally different
abstraction for applications and
operations and provides a much richer
better set of tools and from a develop
from a business person point of view
clusters allow your teams to be much
more productive within the existing set
of resources they have and with the
announcement today we've embraced
clustering for a multi cloud world so
let's go through how first we're going
to talk about containers and how
containers are changing the world and
second will go into Cooper Nettie's and
Google containing engine and talk about
why it's the best way to run your Linux
application containers as we talk to
customers around the world containers
are absolutely changing their lives it's
making it much easier to develop build
and run their applications and doctor
has done a fantastic job at this they've
made it very simple to build a container
make it portable and customers are
picking that up as is the industry
containers are a much better abstraction
and they're targeted at the right layer
so to talk about how let's take a step
backwards this is a virtual machine
obviously and with vanilla virtual
machines I have an idealized piece of
hardware here I'm able to have full
access from the guest Colonel on upwards
I have my library in my applications it
gives me full control at the same time
it has its downsides it's not portable
that idealized piece of hardware is tied
to the VM image itself it's opaque and
customers cannot bring that and move it
across clouds and across providers and
so we see customers running into this
problem they want to get more
utilization are the resources they side
by side deploy apps that they own and
the libraries are conflicting and from
that perspective they start to go down a
few Rob few roads one is they might
restrict the app development cycle they
might restrict the libraries and that
impedes the ability to make Richard
applications and the other one is they
add integration cycles so that
application developers get pulled into
host integration problems and that does
not improve the ops life cycle either
and some approaches we've seen with
customers is they give every application
version its own virtual machine so here
I absolutely have isolation each
application is put into this idealized
piece of hardware they have a vm to
itself and of course the libraries are
not conflicting that's okay but the
redundancy here will cost me I have this
guest layer that's spanning in each VM
it's more to maintain and more
importantly that kernel has a different
velocity than the application on top I
want to be able to control and
articulate each independently I don't
want to manage my apps like I manage my
Colonels the next challenge is it
creates problems for planning for peak
utilization customers are over
provisioning and that further slows down
the procurement cycle and their app
development cycle and so we get two
containers containers create the right
abstraction at the right layer docker
has done a great job at this your app is
special from this perspective of the
library and the app code on top we're
taking an idealized piece of hardware
and we're lifting up and instead
creating an idealized operating system
it's portable it spins up on the order
of process and you're not locked in so
we can compose those and we can take
many application containers and side by
side put them on it onto a node each
container and each application in a
container is I has its isolation from
the library's perspective at the same
time we're able to preserve the same
portability aspects so this is a big
improvement from what we had before but
we're still talking about the individual
node level Google could not operate if
it programmed at individual nodes gmail
search they're all looking at a higher
level construct and so that higher-level
construct that we really need as part of
our solution is a cluster a cluster is
simply a collection of nodes and a set
of tools to help you manage that way
so we talked about containers we talked
about clusters now let's talk about we
talked about containers we introduced
clusters let's let's talk about Google
container engine and given the start of
a new product it's important for us to
go back and we can look at three
influencers influences in how we built
the product the first is google itself
we have over a decade of cluster
computing experience within google it's
informed and create and been a key part
of the lessons in how we build container
engine the second is we've been talking
to customers they've provided us key
inputs as we built out our product and
the third is uber Nettie's itself cooper
Nettie's is the open source project
started by google it's a cluster compute
with full implementation out in the open
and it's been a key influence on
container engine so at Google we
launched over 2 billion containers every
week and from that from we find that we
could not operate in this level if we
focus at the node level we have to be
thinking at the cluster level so some of
the important lessons from clustering
within Google is that you want to let
your users in our in this case
developers of gmail and search you want
them to operate and tell you what they
want to achieve you want them to specify
the intent your system should provide
the constructs to implement the how and
you don't want to Mar the to the next
important point is you want to make it
resilient from day one you want the
cluster to help you with your resiliency
you don't want to be back porting in
resilient patterns and the last is that
you want to keep the system and
architecture pluggable within Google we
have many layered systems and many
separate systems and customers can users
can compose actions based on using those
different systems and at the same time
those systems can have components
swapped out and plugged in so we can be
evolve over time for container engine
the next key input has been talking to
our users and talking to our users we
see that they're trying to deploy ten
hundreds and thousands of containers and
even though we're talking at Google
about deploying two billion containers
every week those lessons also apply here
we see that customers are struggling
though
they're struggling with host based tools
and patterns that are taking away from
the original promise of portability it's
locking them into a set of patterns that
are rigid now and won't let them scale
so we want to address those at the same
time we also see that when we talk to
our large customers they are already
telling us they're running in a multi
cloud world for them they need their
tools to also support multiple clouds
and the third input into container
engine has been Cooper Nettie's if you
don't know Cooper Nettie's is Google's
invitation to build cluster computing in
the open here it started in june and
it's since grown and done success has
been very successful some of the key
lessons we've had from Cooper Nettie's
have been we start in the open all our
design discussions start very detailed
we evolved from the goal level up and we
work with the community as we design out
the patterns and we know that crew
benetti's will work across multiple
clouds our partners our community
they've helped us shape the api's and
they've implemented to their cloud
providers as well so we know that kuber
Nettie's will work if you take it and
install it on any cloud provider of
choice and from that perspective there's
a third important lesson it's the same
as we had within Google which is keep
the system and the architecture
pluggable and from that customers and
partners can tune it and take default
implementation and evolve it as they
need so let's take a quick moment to
take stock on Cooper Nettie's Cooper
Nettie started in june and in the five
months it's since grown it started with
a contribution from google and now has
over a hundred users 100 contributors as
well as over 4,000 github stars it has
nine partners all from the top tier that
are extending and making Cooper Nettie's
work on their clouds and we're adding
more at the same time we've been hard at
work implementing more features we went
from we just recently released 0 for 2
and we added Richard scheduling
integrations with open source logging
tools as well as improvements in our DNS
integration so what is kubinashi's
Cooper neighs as the technology has done
great but
let's briefly dive into some of the
concepts that are important for cluster
computing the first key concept is a pod
this pattern of co-locating two pieces
of code is prevalent everywhere an
example could be I have a content
management system it's providing static
content for my engine next web server
you always want these to be scheduled
together a pod gives you a simple
ability to do so importantly a pod does
not interfere with your app development
cycle your developers are producing
containers and the ops users are
creating these pods that wrap them once
I have a pod I'm able to declare and
define how to create the pod within a
manifest and that gives me this
repeatability I can create a pod and if
the physical machine underneath it dies
I know how to recreate the identical pod
pods also serve as a place where we can
assign something called labels so labels
is a lesson that we've learned through
many bruised knuckles within Google
before we had labels are before the idea
of labels one thing's people started to
do was they started to build higher
level systems and dashboards by looking
at how deployments were occurring and
they're smart and they're able to
reconstruct and identify what might be
there front end or their different
serving systems but if you let your
users get mired into the details it
creates a brittle architecture that
doesn't let them grow and also impedes
as you evolve your system so labels
solve this problem it gives you a piece
of metadata it's specific to your need
and in this example I can have a system
on the right-hand side who all they want
to know is all the v2 error systems it's
completely independent they can assign
labels to the pods and the pods
themselves can be queried for v2 systems
and on the other side I can have all the
front ends so these are constructs that
can build over each other and labels
also serve as something which will call
a membership identifier you can use a
label to trigger higher level systems
and the example would be replication
controllers replication controllers in a
coup brunette ease world is just one
kind of controller I can have other
kinds like a job controller that runs
things to completion but a replication
controllers main function is to ensure
that pods stay up at the disease
h state and for a replication
controllers desired state that's the
number of pods that i want running the
other part with replication controllers
is i can compose and trigger actions in
this example i can have on the right
hand side a v2 system that i want a
canary test I can use the replication
controller to specify the desired state
and I have fine control over adding each
pot as it goes out and if any of the
system dies if the hardware fails a
replication controller will ensure that
the number of pods are up and running
based on the desired state the next
higher level system and the last I'll
discuss is services so if we take a step
back for a moment and stop thinking
about clusters and we think about a
container and a single node I have a
container how do i find it how do I
discover it and that's the problem that
services solves I can create a service
it serves as a stable endpoint for my
clients to bind to if the pods and the
implementation that the service routes
to die the front end client are the
client of the pregnant service does not
need to rebind so services provide this
stable endpoint and allows us to create
these richer microservices that you're
off personnel can create and it does not
infer opinions on to the development
cycle so let me give an example here I
have a services front end and I have two
separate replication controllers if I
want to take the front end if I want to
take one of the pods off line I can take
it away from the service and then I can
access that pod I can ssh into the
containers itself debug look at the logs
i have that fine-grained control of my
system my service stays live the
browsers are still hitting that service
in this example and the service will
route to the pods that exist and with
the other replication controller i can
scale out it's important here that the
replication controller and the services
are decoupled systems and you have that
fine-grained control so
kuber Nettie's we feel is the best way
for you to get to build your cluster
computing infrastructure so let's say
you don't want to build it for many of
our users they do want access to the
implementation but for some of our
customers they want a product or service
that does that for them this is why we
built Google container engine Google
container engine takes inspiration from
a decade of cluster computing within
Google it's inspired by our open source
community and it reimagines the cluster
computing experience for our users and
it puts the power in their hands so you
have a cluster at your fingertips and
with our support for Cooper Nettie's you
have support for a multi cloud world as
well let's pull it all together i have a
google container engine system on one
side i have a single set of api and
tools through those single set of api
and tools I can manage my cluster and
that Cooper Nettie's workload with
Cooper Nettie's I have the open source
community I have dr. support I also have
the ability to orchestrate containers
it's portable and I preserve that with
container engine I'm able to spin up a
cluster in seconds it manages the Cooper
Nettie's workload for me and it
provisions the underlying system now
let's give a demo to pull that all
together and for that demo let's rejoin
proppy so we want to show a cluster in
the workload we want to show that the
customers can bring their containers
without modification and from that
perspective once i have the containers
themselves i can create these constructs
like services etc and it gives me full
control it starts with a node but i
don't have to actually manage the minoan
myself i have a cluster to do that the
cluster will create the notes so to see
that let's show how we would create a
cluster so I use the command the same
come on again ok Google create a new
container and drink Lester I already
have one it's called gcp life so let's
see how I really create it so I'm
ringing the country's i'm using a new
command group that is called container
i'm using the cluster subcommands i want
to create my
trust in us on harwin be I give it a
name and a number of note yeah I want
three node and here you go you have your
cluster Eric great and let's just take a
brief step back and peek behind the
covers and see how these clusters these
nodes are implemented for that I can try
to release I can least like the
instances that are running in the same
zone as soon as the cluster of the same
compute engine instances i see i add
four instances the first one is the
master it's all doing like the API
server that we make that oh come on line
two will talk to you the 3 o's a vm are
running nodes there's no doubt gonna be
that's that's a note that we couldn't
get used for joining the actual
container walk log great the KH there is
just a moniker for Cooper Nettie's it's
saying that we're using Cooper now is to
create the cluster and these are the
same rock solid VMs that not need talked
about so that's great i have a cluster
it has nodes it has a master to
orchestrate all that and from here on
out I'm going to think at the app or the
cluster level and from the app
perspective let's take a look at the
application itself so here I'm going to
one of the node on pop 1980 and I can
see that they have the same were played
on the die running the previous demos
exact same docker container that are
running on Google continue engine if i
click on my front and we talked to my
back end and compile and run the go
codes that i specified here great and so
here the client that were illustrating
is a browser the browser is connecting
into this front end here the frontier is
connecting into a back end here and
we're using the cluster constructs of a
service to encapsulate that frontline
service i'm sorry the front interior as
well as the back end and so from a
client or the browser's perspective it
just needs to know the front end service
address so let's take a look at those
services so I'm going to leave the
services by using the services
subcommand now so I give the name of
Acosta my zone and I leave them so here
i can see that i have three services the
30th of fronting services there is a
selective associated to it and a bot so
what is nine gng is the potted I each in
my border before and what the selector
means is that every time I was our et
some point you will try to find the part
that match this letter which will
dispatch will dispatch and load balancer
request across any part that magic where
we evolved from them and similarly I
have a service for my back end so you
remember when I eat this one button in
the application I want to send this like
glue code to some of the background to
compile and run it and what the front
and pot will actually do is contact the
back-end service on port 8080 and
similarly the request will get your
balance across any pods that match the
query whole back end great and so with
these services I have the ability to
independently marriage each application
all right and the application itself is
implemented into pods but the caller
does not need to know that color just
knows to bind to the service and so we
property and I are managing the front
end in this example so let's take a look
at the positive
so i can see that i have 3 pod running
the pitfalls of front-end you can see
here that I have the same collection of
lab bed I was talking about the front
enough tagged with whole front end and
you have the back and put in its type
with the Lebel of whole back end I can
see the nodes where they are running and
I can also see the container image are
going to hear you see that i'm using the
same container image i was using the
previous demo great and so we only have
one instance of the front-end pod let's
say that we've been wildly successful
from the earlier demo and go playgrounds
getting tons of traffic I want to scale
out the number of front-end pods but I
want to do it at a desired state as an
ops user I don't want to have to
imperative really recreate each pod we
have cluster tools to do so so with that
we would use a replication controller
property can you show us a replication
controller yeah I'm going to take a look
at the manifest file replication
controller so here the first thing of HD
arrest is the bottom plate it's what
defines a workflow that we want to ram
so we have a simple y ml manifest that
is compromised of two container composed
of two company the first container is a
good application it's my front end it's
a dynamic part of my app that will like
display so you I and under the request
here it's a it's an image that is called
go play and I the thing which is
interesting is that I have another
container in the same pod an engines
container and this container is used to
self static file and since it's too
contain are co-located like inside the
same pod it's trivial for the photo for
the engine spot to offload dynamic
request to the Go app and the pod itself
behave like a single entity and get
scheduled by communities and always move
from not to not together this last
container so engines container is
exposing a port it's exposing port 80
and the name of the port is web server
this is a part that gets reference
inside the service definitions left shin
area something also interesting is the
labels that we set on this boat every
time the replication controller create a
new pottage will associate whole front
end to this the level to this bird so
our replication controller needs to
parameter in order to scare off part it
needs a number of replicas that we want
to keep in the system here we want five
and you need to a replica selector which
is a query that it will run across the
cluster to know
there is like too many pod or not enough
so at any point of this is at any point
of time my replication controller will
query this is the cluster with this
whole front end replica selector if
there is say for pod running it will
start a new one is there is six box
running it will kill one and so I can
try to I can I can like use this
configuration know and like scale my
front end part 4 125 so for that I'm
going to use the container command with
a replication controller common group
I'm going to point to the manifest after
Sean and here you have i scared you're
fronting eric great but what about the
pod ok i will actually show you that
it's true so let's get the part again
and here you can see that i have a form
of board running what's interesting is
that the replication controller only
created for because we already had one
part in the system matching this replica
selector so it it already needed to
create for too much desired state that
we expressing more manifest right so
you're able to take a replicate use a
replication controller to scale your
friend instances let's take it back to
the application what does it look like
so here i have the same application I
cannot refresh my browser and you see
that it's still serving it's still
working and we in the middle change
number of pods that are running which is
actually happening when I eat my buzzer
is that I eat the service on points and
the service on point here will find
anybody including the new one I created
to serve this request and similarly when
i click fun the go code will get some to
the to the back-end service on point and
the new front-end pot that I that I
created they don't have to learn about
where the back end is they don't have to
discover them they already know about
the back-end service on point so all
they need to do is to contacts at one
point and the request will get
dispatched to one of the back end but
that match the labelled sector query on
the service and that's it thanks
property so the important part for me as
an ops user is that we are able to take
a live service it was resilient we're
able to have one of the pods be touched
attenuated and we
use a replication controller so the
cluster concepts to help me manage my
desired state and for the developers
they did not have to change the code
they did not have to be mired in the
details of how I built that resilient
microservice so to recap we have a new
service google container engine it gives
you a cluster within seconds and it lets
you have fine-grained control over
desired state it's designed for a multi
cloud world with support for Kuber
Nettie's and on behalf of the Google
team it's my pleasure to share that we
are open alpha today please go use it
and give us share with us your feedback
and we're working hard with updates on
pricing and SLA s with that please let
me welcome our next speaker astrid
atkinson is a engineering manager at
Google App Engine product and she's here
to share with us more about App Engine
thank you
hi everyone so as Eric said my name is
Astrid and I'm an engineering manager
here at google so container engine is
really great technology for when you
want to exercise super fine-grained
control over how your production
services are configured and deployed
across your compute resources but let's
take a step back and talk for a minute
about managing systems instead of it I'm
going to take a step back instead of
talking about managing systems let's
talk about managing applications so as a
developer in the cloud there's a lot of
stuff that you have to take care of you
know stuff like getting mera code onto
multiple machines managing production
configuration resource provisioning and
so forth which might really not be how
you want to spend all of your time you
know a lot of this stuff is really just
overhead it's the same every time you
have to do it it's similar for most
applications and it's similar for most
users and so at a certain point it might
be nice just to kind of let the machines
take care of it for you and so that's
what appengine was really built for and
I'm going to talk a little bit about
what we're doing with App Engine and how
we're working to evolve the platform so
a typical serving stack kind of starts
here you know if you're developing a new
application you're going to start with a
single node and there'll be the stuff
that you really care about which is your
app code your libraries and so forth
they'll be the application environment
then there's the guest Colonel the OS
the hypervisor all the stuff associated
with the VM and within the app
environment there's also a few elements
that are pretty generic right you're
pretty much always going to have a web
server you're pretty much always going
to have an app server usually going to
be a language runtime interpreter and so
forth and so App Engine was really built
originally to abstract these components
right they provide these this kind of
general-purpose platform so let's say
that here's where you start with a
single node but as you're moving from
dev to prod that's probably not what you
end right you're probably going to want
a whole bunch of notes and then you're
going to need a load balancer to accept
traffic for those and send traffic
across all of them and then since you're
running in the cloud you're probably
also going to want to note a scalar so
sighs the pull up as you're getting more
traffic and then slice it back down when
you're not using those resources so you
don't have to pay for them and something
that we've also observed is the
typically over time as applications
mature
the developer will want to divide the
system up into areas of specific
functionality so we showed in the
earlier example a kind of a trivial
example it has a front end and back end
but usually this gets pretty pretty
complex pretty quickly in production a
lot of times they'll be batch processing
feed aggregation upload processing
billing interacting with their party aap
is those kinds of things it gets kind of
a lot more complex over time as your app
grows and then each of these also needs
its own load balancer its own autoscaler
so that you can tune them individually
not a lot and then you probably also
want a high availability configuration
it will be deployed in more than one
zone and then depending on your app
profile you might want to be in more
than one region right you might want to
get next to your users for latency
reasons and if you're a global company
you may also want to do this globally so
discuss complex pretty quickly and
that's before you even consider things
like updates rollouts rollbacks and so
forth now all of the stuff about
managing your application over time so
one of the things that we've observed at
Google is that while large services can
afford the overhead of dedicating ops
area DevOps stuff to managing all of
this production infrastructure for a lot
of services having to manage all of this
really creates drag in terms of the
amount of innovation that a team can
generate right if the developers on a
team are spending all of their time
working on running stuff in production
that's time they're not spending
building stuff for users and so
something that we noticed at Google as
we tried to abstract these common layers
so people didn't have to worry about it
so much is it really tended to increase
the rate of innovation on the team as
developers were able just to focus on
building awesome applications for users
and App Engine was originally the
externalization of this philosophy right
the idea that we could take and abstract
all of the common elements of running a
system so that developers could really
just focus on their code and Google
could kind of take care of the rest and
provide a suite of tools for managing
that application over time so over the
past year we've been working really hard
on boldness so particularly focusing on
openness and flexibility back in cloud
life in March we announced managed VMs
which is a pension environment
engine management infrastructure with
virtual machines so with the new app
engine environment you get the same high
productivity you can focus on your code
and Google can handle all the plumbing
scaling the load balancing provisioning
and all of that stuff but you can now do
it with any compute engine vm which
means that you can access different
except ram and cpu footprints and you
can also access all of the tools
associated with the underlying GC a
layer that's kind of cool it's also more
flexible because you can choose all of
the libraries and dependencies that your
app needs and if the App Engine runtime
doesn't work for you you don't need to
use it at all right you can just bring a
container that has your own runtime in
it and the management infrastructure can
take care of that for you since the
initial launch we've been super hard at
work adding features and also working on
reliability so a couple of things we've
added our integration with some of the
cloud platform tools load balancing
integration with GCL b cloud autoscaler
integration integration with the cloud
SDK so this is really easy just from a
tooling perspective to drop down to the
underlying infrastructure when you need
to and then we also added docker support
so that you can take advantage of the
portability and the flexibility that the
containerized environment provides and
best of all I'm super happy to announce
that as of today we're opening this up
to public beta so you can take advantage
of this with your own workloads right
now and you know let us know if you like
it oh all right so with that we're going
to have back over to property for one
last demo okay so as a string motion
sometimes there is sometimes like when
you I will develop them and you don't
really want to worry about vm you don't
even want to worry about clustering or
container you only want to focus on your
app and so that we can use the same come
on again I hope you the joke will not
get too old ok Google take care of my
use App Engine and so that's what I'm
going to do I'm going to run the same
demo that we've deployed before on
compute engine that we orchestrate on
communities to and like running on Mac
laptop using Google App Engine SDK so
let's take a peek at the back end we
focused a lot of the on the front and
rooms equivalent is demo now I want to
talk more about the back end so my
background is a piece of go code I have
a doctor
five for each you know about to build a
container that it will build the same
container that I use for the previous
demo sense to document ability and the
only thing I actually do in order to
transform this docker container into an
app engine app is to add a dirty ml file
so let's take a look at what the adult
email file looks like so some of you may
be already familiar with the appeal app
engine configuration we define a module
name hero module is back end we define
deduction but here there is two new
flags that I would like to introduce you
there is a vm to flag it tells that we
want to run on managed VM and there is a
one-time custom flag even if we are
using a go up here it's not like you're
holding hands go up it's actually
compiling your code it's running in a
sandbox it's pretty custom so for that
we need to bring our own runtime we need
to bring our own local container and
that's what the runtime custom stands I
saying it's saying like using the Duca
file that i have in the same directory
took my app code and build a container
for it so let's see how we can use the
cloud SDK to run both the front end and
the back end on my laptop so here it
will build the container for my front
end in my background and ends oakland
and the fronton will start serving on
port 8080 so i can go to localhost and
here i have like the same application
that i have before with my two
components my to module and when i click
on the front and talk to the background
module compile my go code run it and
alternator put so i think like the app
is ready now I've tested it it's Bocking
locally and i want to deploy it in
prediction so for that i use the g-cloud
preview up command but with the deployed
keyboard and here i am deploying a new
version of my app in production so same
it will it will compile my goal my
container if they are not already there
and start provisioning my vm with the
containers that are running in them so i
already need to deploy the other version
before this event and here we can see
it's running on my own app ID on my
owner's name i can click run and
similarly the front end is talking to
the back and compiling my go code and
running out and we just want to
like post a little bit and think about
like all the things that we
automatically get done for you we we
didn't have to worry about provisioning
is a vm with a container like the
deploying system automatically copied or
container into Google Cloud storage and
provision the vm so they can fetch this
container on honey we don't really have
to worry about creating a load balancer
or dns entry or even another scale of
our app like when we are eating this
earth name it's automatically gets load
balance and auto scale because one of
our module if we are getting more
traffic for example when go one dot for
launch in the following weeks or maybe
want I don't know and like so the
infrastructure when people will rush to
the doctor to the go playground in order
to try some new good one dot for feature
the app will be available and be able to
understand I fix bike and also we didn't
have to worry about like copying static
file or provisioning front end and
making sure to get cash all of static
file gets upload to Google rock solid
front end and get cash automatically so
I want to take a peek and also color and
see what so app is looking inside the
console so um here when I go into the
App Engine section of the console I have
like I have an overview that give you
like some earth metric for my app I can
see the latency I can see the more
popular on point when I app and if i
want i can dive into the version i
deployed here i can see that i have two
version version 1 and version to the
type and with one click i can enable
traffic splitting and say would like say
ten percent of my traffic to version two
and so I get to be able to test change
with real user without compromising my
life services I can also take a look at
what instance are running so here for my
front an aging aging of actually getting
new traffic but I could take one here or
load and instance should start or I
could even take a look at my background
I can see that I have back to back and
running that
morning request I can see some a present
metric like loading latency or even even
a latency for requests and I can also
look at the logs of each module so here
I can take a look at the logs for my
back end for example and see that you
don't let the bunch of my requests but
sometimes you need to go deeper like I
said that you don't want really think
about GM you're not where you think
about clustering but sometime you need
to you need to take a look at this VM
that is running your app and for that
you just need to go to the instant
section and when you click here you
actually go to the compute engine
section of the console and here you can
see more machine type blood n matrix
like CPU geez Asian or network traffic
on this traffic you can also see our
underlying it's free transparent Nichols
you see also underlying like vm get
provision which parameter i get used
with ska-p it has a new API Cowen's able
to make you can even an ssh to it if you
need to troubleshoot and you can like
use the container using the standard
local tour so with that I will go back
to us trade and thanks for watching the
demo alright thanks so much preppy um
actually can you guys take it back one
slide thank you so to recap we just
showed a couple of things one is that
portability is really key to the compute
continuum right property was able to
take the same container that we used in
the raw vm and the auto scaling demo to
start with run that in container engine
and then also run that in App Engine
without any modifications another is it
is pretty easy to move back and forth he
showed you a little bit of the
configuration it's really just as simple
as making a config change and the last
is that all of the additional
application support stuff that comes
along with App Engine can really make it
a lot easier to maintain your app
without having to worry about setting
all of that up for yourself so this is
functionality that really aligns with a
few core principles just kind of getting
back to this which guide our thinking
about what makes a great cloud platform
so first is developer efficiency and we
think it should be really easy to get
started it should be pretty
straightforward it should be zero
friction you know things that should
work should work
well together and when you're ready to
move from local development to
production should be just a click
likewise when you want to move from your
tests and senses to your production
instances that should also be really
straightforward but we wouldn't really
be doing you any favors if the whole
system fell over just at the point where
you started to reach real success right
as your app scale is up the
infrastructure needs to scale with you
and so by building on Google
infrastructure we're able to guarantee
that we'll be able to scale with you
whether you have a hundred users or 100
million or a billion hopefully let us
know if you have a billion and also by
building on top of the underlying
generally available compute engine and
cloud platform elements all the power
and flexibility of the infrastructure as
a service platform is available to you
as well without having to punch out of
the App Engine environment and lastly
we're doing this in the open we're
starting to build out runtimes on github
where you can fork them customize them
or even replace them if you want to now
as we showed earlier with container
engine we're building on top of open
source systems to build the
functionality that we're rolling out
today and the ecosystem is growing at a
phenomenal pace right now right like
those open source systems are really
leading the way and here at Google we
believe that the future the cloud
platform is genuinely wide open so with
that I'll hand back to Neff who's going
to talk a little bit about the road
ahead thank
thanks Astrid so what have we learned
and where are we going well first we
really believe that you need to think
about operations from the get-go it
really is all about operations if you're
building a successful application and so
we want to make sure that those early
design design decisions that drive your
long-term costs and make your
applications either maintainable or not
as easy as possible to make we want to
make sure you have the right building
block so you can factor your application
in a way that makes sense and then we
want to help all of our developers
fundamentally fall into the pit of
operational success in other words you
want to make it as easy as possible for
you to get started right so that things
just work well from there on kuba Nettie
is the first project in cloud that we've
done in the open in the open source
community and we've learned a lot from
it the community has really helped us
shape the API it's helped us build a
better product unlocked the ecosystem
with the broad list of partners that
Eric talked about it's let us iterate
very quickly and in the open and we look
forward to trying that model with other
projects in the future and then finally
you should start thinking about compute
not as a set of different services but
as a continuum of abstractions where you
can pick and choose the right
abstractions for your applications or
components and change your mind without
incurring a significant penalty so you
can move up and down the abstraction
stack and focus on building your
application and let us to the rest for
you thank you